basic internet as a human right people
they say healthcare that's all right
before that phone what that wasn't in
English Decker you're in a gang or
something they're right to adopt
children boom one year pattern you see
for father that's okay I won't tell
nobody I see mother Collis hi everyone
as juggy Trombley last time together we
were feeling the burn but now it's time
to take the another step for right you
ma'am in the United States that's why
I'm Air Force enter the progress for hmm
to get people to sign petition for equal
rights and human right for everybody the
balloon is up in the way like Dominic we
wanted to see how many people would sign
on to rights paid for by the government
man I was getting so many signature I
need to buy more pupcake
so like we just want people to sign for
basic human right you are that's it so
we want to start like to bring people
together for just bait like sign for the
government for basic rights you man like
in Quebec health care is right for
everybody it's good for health care to
be right for everybody in Quebec you
need health care no problem
are used to them yeah dying that's
education it costs for free like we sign
that yeah that's it what about is like
down there
Quebec is no no not a trick
no kbecque is in Canada why should you
have to pay you pay a lot for them it's
just basic place for people to sleep and
live as human right like that if you
don't have a house to start and care is
not going to do something you know
everybody is of course support free
health care education and housing from
the government but we wanted to push the
envelope and see how many rights paid
for by the government we could get for
all the real people's hockey thing
people they say health care that's all
right before that food transportation
like do you have a car like you have a
skateboard but not everybody is AB that
you know basic Internet as a human right
that's at Internet you don't have like
an iPhone or whatever basic do you pay
for internet do you have I go on my
laptop how much you pay for them too
much too much like that
take care one year paid leave for mother
furniture like that people basic like
this I'm not from Michigan okay then
what are you good for Durst you're
blocking my shop same thing we don't
want to be sexist paid paternity issue
that everyone can be you know the right
to fitness center to BLT always 100% on
that one okay
your sign for that hygiene product
that's of course a right to man basic
like that back to basic as my teacher
away six they're right to adopt children
there's lots of people that not have
children people want to adopt
there are mystery free rights paid for
by the government is beautiful because
it's bring everybody together even gay
black guys who are in the gang your
preference you're like I'm not gay but
if people they want to do that they have
the right to do that you know but you
know what I mean like like I'm not gay I
don't like if you're gay that's cool
you're in a gang or something huh
and you know that guy is he like in like
a rival gang or something people have
the right to do that
to have sex with the people they want
that's it all right that's cool man but
I'm not gay
so one can say hey no don't do that no
no no not Sookie you don't want to test
your okay my man all that there don't
move okay that's cool if you're gay I'm
not having problem I'm not here to judge
for that and it's not just for gay black
guy rights paid for by the government is
bring all the people's together have a
grant he'll they go I'm not going to
tell nobody
yeah that's ok I won't tell nobody yes I
see mother
Karlis I love me I've mean with Louise
Carl is ok to immigrants we have to
stick together and even people whose
confusion g:c kalus excuse me excuse me
mister madam can you for two mom person
but I'm not going to judge I even get
all the people to sign to ban the Second
Amendment because Sandy Hook you know
you don't need that make it more safe
like Quebec we don't have so we want to
make take away the Second Amendment so
people like me can be safe but of the
right to know more Afghan hey it's going
great
everybody is one too
sign this right for nothing nothing uh
chorus everybody's give interviews sign
on for every single ride that's one
thing but it's another thing to take
that fight to the government you can't
everybody need like a care and education
for them you can do that it's just not
thing okay let's go before that like
people like that they know it's
important and this time of politics
where people get mad and divide to
remember what's bring everybody together
free right from the government and pay
nothing
Gobbo Sabah comme si comme si comme si
comme si let me arrest little jewel